you haven't done an episode on sex well
we did an episode early on on sexual
development yes we've done them on
optimizing testosterone and estrogen and
we touched a little bit on the
uh on libido
and somewhat on sex performance but not
much
we did an episode on relationships love
and desire
where we touched on libido specifically
so just as a quick mention of something
a lot of people take ssris or
antidepressants that can disrupt sexual
function there are a few compounds like
maca root and tonga ali and things like
that that at least in a few studies in
humans have been shown to offset some of
the sexual side effects
now in terms of sexual and then sorry
the episode on sexual development was
about how the brain and body become
organized in certain ways how the brain
becomes organized if you have x
chromosomes or y chromosomes or etc so
early early early development mainly and
the effects of hormones later on that
template
we will be doing a i'm actually putting
together a series on sexual health
everything from
the menstrual cycle which both men and
women should understand of course
um understanding arousal
understanding for instance a lot of
people don't realize this but that
orgasm is actually the consequence of
activity in the
sympathetic meaning the stress arm of
the autonomic nervous system
whereas arousal
is the consequence of the activity of
the parasympathetic the calming aspect
of the of of the autonomy it's
counterintuitive right it's
counterintuitive and it kind of works
like a seesaw i mean there's arousal
then there's relaxation then there's
arousal but the
um and then immediately after
orgasm
and in males ejaculation what ends up
happening is there's a rebounding of the
parasympathetic nervous system which it
leads to oftentimes people feeling very
relaxed or falling asleep
so i'm going to do a short series on
sexual health that will be that will
include stuff about sexual performance
but also um
some i i'm working on getting an expert
guest who can talk about some of the
neurologic changes that happen
as a consequence of sexual activity and
we did an episode with a guy from ut
austin here david buss who's
evolutionary psychologist talking about
um we went pretty deep into some of the
uh typical and unusual dynamics of of
mating relation
whether or not people have kids or not
and what impacts that but we're going to
do an episode on menopause andropause
what's very surprising is i get a lot of
questions about sexual health from the
young male audience
[Music]
which tells me that
well here's what i think it reflects i
think that women because of their
menstrual cycles early on start to talk
to one another about changes in
physiology and psychology as a function
of this 28-day cycle that they all
experience sooner or later
males there's less of a conversation and
it usually arrives in code people say
hey what should i take to increase my
testosterone and i'll say well maybe
nothing you know
what are you specifically concerned
about and then over time if you pull on
those threads a little bit
you know you get your answer sometimes
i'll just get a direct question
but i think that
the psychology of all this and in terms
of jealousy and the terms of um notions
of of uh roles and relationships is very
dynamic right now and i'm fascinated by
this so we're gonna do a four episode
series what about sexual fantasy
what uh to get freudian for a second
what role does sexual fantasy have
in the human condition
there's a book called the erotic
imagination it's a very psychoanalytic
book written by a psychoanalyst that
talks about
um how
well here's the uncomfortable reality
freud was at least right about one thing
which is that the brain circuitry that
you used to develop attachments to your
caregivers mother and father or other
caregivers
do not disappear when you hit puberty
they are repurposed for romantic and
sexual relations
and so this is why the whole notion of
anxious attached and secure attached you
know stems from childhood attachment
patterns but it carries over to romantic
relationships
so that the relationship with your
mother has
and father has a
and probably other close people to you
and your young age has
a
secondary tertiary some kind of ripple
effect on how your sexuality developed
like what fantasies you might have all
that oh without question and of course
early experiences too and traumatic or
positive or or neutral the thing that's
really important to remember though in
this transfer of circuitry from one role
to another is that
and it's certainly consistent with
psychoanalysis that gender is
interchangeable
sex is interchangeable so for instance
let's say you had a wonderful
relationship let's say this let's take a
hypothetical person okay i'm truly not
referring to myself let's take a a a
young woman who has a wonderful
relationship to her father
and a just absolutely terrible abusive
relationship to her mother just for sake
of example
she then goes into adulthood and
she is drawn to very abusive
men not always but let's just use in
this example
and the dynamic is exactly the same as
the dynamic she had with her mother
that's actually a common occurrence even
though
in this context she's heterosexual she's
romantically attracted to men what is
seen over and over again is that the
dynamic with one parent can be
transferred onto a romantic dynamic but
it doesn't have to be you know that if
it was with the mother then it only has
to do with relationships to women so
gender is interchangeable because these
circuitries
are pre-sexual they're laid down in our
brain before the brain has any concept
of sexual interactions it's pre-pubertal
excuse me
and so um there are a lot of interesting
examples and data to support this um
the book attached is a pretty
interesting book by two psychologists
one i think is at columbia university um
that talks about how childhood dynamics
uh carry over to adult uh romantic
attachment so as you can tell i get
pretty alert in response to these
questions i get a lot of them really in
this domain and they have a lot of
impact on people and they're wondering
about they want to learn and no one
knows what other people are doing or
what's normal we kind of know deviancy
we know perversion we know the extremes
yeah we know the rules hopefully people
know the rules but
you know
let's just be there are a lot of people
in in the academic community in
particular at certain east coast schools
not to be named that are
in open relationships this is more
common now
um it's not
very common but it's more common yeah
and you know obviously that's a way of
bypassing some of these more primitive
emotions about jealousy etc and
leveraging them towards maybe even
ongoing relationships i'm not passing
judgment one way or the other i always
say
four conditions have to be met for any
discussion about about sex and sexuality
or sexual health age appropriate
context appropriate
consensual and species appropriate
you